Drive by day Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
So,
so let's back up.
I made a note here on that Jon Jones thing.
Did you follow the whole Johnstones drama and the most recent one?
The only post drama?
Yeah.
Was that he had a press conference the next day.
Did,
did you follow that press conference at all?
I saw the crying pictures.
Okay.
Jamie sent them to me.
All right.
I went to that press conference and there was a couple of takeaways and this is
all speculative,
but for this doesn't make John innocent at all.
Well,
John's guilty.
They've got,
they've got the sample.
It's guilty,
but his actions were not that of a guilty man.
Historically guilty guys go bury their head in the sand.
They try to outrun this thing.
They get with their legal teams.
They show up at the hearing.
They hope for the worst,
for the best.
They get the worst than they deal with it.
John faced the music 12 hours later he came through the hotel his whole life
pulling apart.
Right now I imagine he didn't even sleep that night.
He comes to the hotel with the fans.
He comes into the media PR one oh one says you read a script that was written
for you and you exit the stage.
Instead he read no script.
He took every question asked of him and that's just not what a guilty guy does.
Not understand that he's guilty in terms of Lusaka,
but what we care about his intent was he trying to get over on somebody who was
he trying to hide something?
His actions would represent that he did it,
but here was the problem with the press conference.
Joe,
when you hold a press conference,
you have,
you have one goal in mind,
which is to win over the media and that they say nice things about you before
you do go home and bury your head in the sand.
Secondly,
you want to break something.
You want to get something out there to get ahead of the story.
That's the whole reason you show up at these things.
The only car that he had to play is what did you test positive for?
That was the only thing we didn't know and they refuse to reveal it so that,
that was a little bit weird and where I was sitting,
cause I've been at John Spot and here was the thing that happened with me.
We're,
we're talking about John,
this whole thing's going on with John based on a test that took place on June
16th the reason that was relevant when I went through my thing,
I was,
he tested positive for semesters in blockers.
Those don't really have anything to do with anything.
They don't help you.
They're silly.
I think you might've just revealed something.
Yeah,
he tested positive for two estrogen,
but you just no one else knew that.
There you go.
I'm revealing it broke personal information.
That's what we're doing here though.
Right?
Wow.
But this is like,
this is like the only way that anybody could find that out is if you talked
about it.
Boom.
It's out there.
Right.
And that we're doing here,
aren't we creating some news?
That's a big news day.
But listen,
but here's the relevance.
And let me tie myself into this.
When I went through this job,
I had something silly in there.
In fact,
I had an estrogen blocker.
I just something silly in there and everybody for gay I was,
I was going to be suspended,
but fox,
I was fine.
Everybody looked at it,
okay,
well you know we changed the rules and the Tesla and everything was fine,
but what I had to live with,
what only I knew there was another test out there,
but the results hadn't come back yet and I didn't know what that test was going
to show.
I know what it could have shown.
I knew what it should have shown,
but I what the other test could
have been should have as well.
So you're sitting there hoping how good is this damn test?
That's all you're thinking about.
Well,
we,
you and I had a conversation.
You're the guy called you were on stage and I'm blowing you up.
You're like,
hey man,
I'm doing a show.
Can I call you tomorrow?
I go to night.
I will stay at capital letters to night.
I need to hear from you tonight.
I remember the exact words he said,
well,
you know,
we were wondering how stringent these new tests are.
Turns out they're really good.
Turns out it's a pretty good test.
Turns out it's not like the old a one 800 requests a test that costs $99 okay?
There's a reason this caught this test is 40 plus grand.
But the thing that I'm,
I'm wondering,
does John have another test out there?
If he does it doesn't mean it's going to come back,
but that was the same spot I was in.
There was a shoe that could drop for me.
It did for him.
Is there another test out there?
And if there's not,
then who saw has got some explaining to do?
If you're telling me a guy that's got a track record that tested positive for
cocaine,
going to fight in the biggest fight of his career and the last time you tested
him was one month before the bow.
Then Osad has got some explaining to do,
but there's more to the story now.
What do we hear it does?
He passes the end up in the spot.
I don't know,
but that's,
that's the piece that's still missing.
Well,
there's one aspect to his,
uh,
test is positive tests that people are saying could possibly play a factor and
it's a supplements that he could possibly have been taking.
Something that like,
this is what happened to Tim means this is what happened Yoel Romero where they
get a supplement and it says it has a bunch of stuff on it says you look through
the ingredients.
Okay,
creatine B12 we're good,
we're good.
But then when you run it through a lab,
it turns out there's a bunch of other stuff in there too.
And that's why it's so effective and that's why it sells.
So it is possible that that could be the case.
We don't know yet.
Cause then if that's the case,
then John has to give them all the supplements that he was taking.
And then they have to go to a store,
buy them independently,
test them and verify that these ingredients were in not just the bachelor,
he hands them,
but also in other batches.
So it's not like he doctored,
it shows some stuff in there.
Sure.
But estrogen blockers are usually when people are getting off of steroids.
When you're coming off a cycle.
Yeah,
and it's a blocker.
You know,
men don't want estrogen anyway,
but it's a blocker.
It's,
it's not going to.
So as far as that substance goes,
and that's all,
that's all he's going to have to live with.
You're not going to explain,
explain how they work.
Like for someone who doesn't understand what an estrogen blocker will do.
If you up your testosterone,
then your estrogen just naturally ops and guys don't want estrogen.
So if you're a guy,
you,
you take a blocker that can block that,
bring it to it,
you won't get a,
you know that the man's moves.
Where there are you making the,
I'm trying to think of the word guide.
Gas Stove.
I can't,
even when I came from Mitch tits is all that comes to mind.
I can't think of the word guide.
We're closed guide.
I know.
God I know.
Got a mass to go.
At any rate,
it can stop some of those things.
So that's the speculation.
The reason that that's on the list is they find that that's a way they can catch
you after the fact,
Hey,
if we missed you during the cycle,
we can catch you here.
Well,
it's not just that the,
the reason why they take it after the cycle is because you get hypogonadism,
your,
your body stops producing testosterone because you took exogenous testosterone.
That's right.
And so the,
to restart it,
they'd take this stuff,
these estrogen blocker.
Yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
I tested positive for an estrogen blocker and it was that exact thing.
Same thing.
They banned testosterone.
I went on something called Hcg.
She'll return your testes back on and then you have to clomiphene,
which is by definition an estrogen blocker for that same thing,
but can also help get your body going back on testosterone.
So their band,
John's got a problem.
And again,
this comes back to the press conference.
He said,
I have not taken anything new that I have not taken my entire career.
So somebody gave him a followup question.
He quickly realized what he just said and he goes,
wow,
I,
I do have a new supplement company.
I have taken some new supplements.
So he realized he put himself in one point,
you need to get out of it.
The supplement company then who dropped him immediately,
quit,
came out with a press release,
said,
do not put this on us.
We don't have anything to do with that and we'll turn over any samples you want.
So that,
that's,
that's the downside to holding the press conference is if there's anything that
commission hates,
it's when somebody isn't honest with them.
Well,
if there's anything who Sada hates and it's with Lance Armstrong found out,
it's when you deny the scientific accuracy of their test,
that's the risk with holding a press conference.
And that's why most legal teams will tell you,
go home,
be quiet,
rewrite a right to remain silent.
Execute that.
Show up at your hearing date,
gets sworn in,
say your piece,
and then go on about your life.
How does John not have a trusted handler?
How does John not have someone who realizes that you don't just have like a,
uh,
a high level athlete?
You have arguably the greatest light heavyweight of all time,
who has not,
in my opinion,
reached his potential yet I think John has massive potential outside of what
he's actually shown because when he moved to Albuquerque and we saw that he was
training all the time and we saw the most recent footage before he fought over
in Saint Pru where he's power lifting,
he looks fucking huge.
He's dedicated,
his eating clean,
he's making these Instagram videos of all this healthy food he's eating.
We're assuming he's getting the proper rest and all these other things.
We're assuming you'll get the wild man.
Days are gone.
He still got the wild man's mind,
but now he's going to approach this like a real competitive athlete.
Here's my question to you.
When someone is wild and talented and impulsive,
just a wild motherfucker like Jon Jones is,
is it even smart to reign that guy in Ken,
Ken,
it affect him.
I mean,
is it a positive thing to reign him in or is part of what he is and why he's so
good and why he's willing to open with a flying knee on a shogun?
The their their first fight,
I mean the first fight for a title it,
what was He,
2123 or 20 he opens up with a flying knee on,
you know,
one of the legends of MMA,
former pride champion or fry pride up Grand Prix tramp champion and UFC champion
as well.
You will,
you look at a like John and the,
the way he competes in the way he's,
he's so creative and wild in there and impulsive.
It's almost like that's a part of his success.
I fully agree and historically I could bring up athletes where that is true or
they go sober where they go straight in there when they find God,
whatever these things are and they change something that yeah,
the dominoes start to fall.
The problem is when you've got a wild man like John,
he's in a box and it's a loose box and he's having some fights,
but usually that continues to escalate.
So he kinda needs to keep himself right in that framework.
And the bad news is it usually just keeps getting,
it just usually just keeps pushing.
So that's a very important,
that becomes a problem.
That's a very important point where people escalate things like billionaires
want more billions,
right?
They want islands now.
They want fucking jets and spaceships and,
and with a pro athlete or a wild person is doing crazy shit.
They want to do more crazy shit.
They want to drive 150 miles an hour.
Right?
They want to Ah,
man,
but it just seems like whatever the fuck you do,
just,
just nerf everything around him,
you know?
Right.
By up to town.
Fucking have three guys that he trusts.
Follow him around everywhere and make sure that he doesn't eat anything that
he's not supposed to eat.
Sure.
Don't take any pills you're not supposed to take.
Don't,
most of us don't drive.
I mean,
that was his biggest problem was getting behind the wheel in front of everything
else he was doing.
It's like John Jay,
you got to get,
you got to get a show for it.
You've got to get Uber,
you got to take a taxi,
don't get behind the wheel.
That was the most of his problems.
He had some other ones,
but that was the most of it.
If you just took him out of the driver's seat,
a lot of this doesn't exist.
Yeah.
A lot of it doesn't exist.
But this most recent one obviously it does and the most like,
yeah,
he had those,
the co two major car accidents,
we had that beautiful Bentley and slid it into a tree.
Right.
And then,
uh,
obviously the one where you crashing that woman and left the scene of the crime,
which was horrendous.
He survived that though.
You know,
he survived that.
He came back and the,
and Saint [inaudible] he won,
he beat a top six guy on short notice and then this happens and two is he get
positive and something that as a is small and innocuous as estrogen blockers.
Yeah,
I agree.
So you go back to that open state proof fight.
Single worst performance is a performance of John's career.
Single worst by light years.
And then you break it down a little further.
He won the grapple and he won the strike and he won every round.
He didn't,
he didn't back off.
You didn't get tired.
He was stronger.
And that was on a bad day.
I didn't think it was a bad fight.
I,
you know,
everyone says the single worst performance.
I have a great deal of respect for open St Pru and I think [inaudible] is a very
dangerous guy.
He's very explosive.
His left power kick is extremely strong.
He has a nasty left hook.
He's a southpaw and he fights odd.
He has a very odd style.
I would agree about elephants.
I think your assessment there is fair and I think his stock went up that night,
but when I'm watching John,
I'm going,
okay,
this isn't that.
This is a rusty John.
This is slower.
The outputs a little bit down the bottom line
is on a bad day,
he left with a world championship on a bed.
That's how good he is.
The other side of John,
you know when you're talking about the car wrecks or one more time about the
cocaine or what he's going through now,
and again,
this was my takeaway from the press conference.
The biggest takeaway was John won't own anything and it's like John,
at some point you can't do the routine about,
I don't know why God put me in this spot.
This is a bit,
I don't know why God put me in the spot.
Everything happens for a reason.
I'm going to come out better on the other side,
it's like John,
you're acting like you got diagnosed with diabetes or cancer or something,
you know and that you're the victim.
You were in a hit and run.
You did the hidden,
and you did the running.
That was your fault.
On the cocaine thing.
You didn't say,
somebody slipped me a Mickey.
You said,
I was at a party in Brazil.
I rolled up a hundred and went down to the table.
That was your fault.
Now you're in a jam here for two banned substances and you're still not taking
respond and you think God's put you in this spot.
It's like John said,
you put yourself in this spot and at some point if you're the baddest dude in
the world and you are,
you got to man up on these things.
You got to man up and go,
Hey,
I'm guilty and I how exactly it happened.
I'm,
I'm going to try to figure that out,
but I'm definitely guilty who Sada does a good job.
I trust those labs.
Let's get to the bottom of it.
Jail son in public relations.
This is what we need.
We need to here need a little earpiece.
You put in John Jones ear.
You sit behind the screens,
you have a monitor.
You Go,
no,
no.
John.
This is not just stop.
Stop right there,
but no more victim no more.
Yeah,
you stand up like Tony Montana and that fucking restaurant.
You're looking at the back guy there to say hello there it is.
Low through the bad guy.
Yeah.
I liked to party.
Bitch,
I fucked up.
I took some shit.
Uh,
what,
so what supplements would have testosterone blockers or estrogen blockers,
excuse none that I've ever heard of and again,
but,
but if they boost testosterone,
estrogen blockers,
apparently the is more of an effective test off.
How's it work?
I'm not,
I've never heard that.
And that could be true.
I think of myself as kind of an expert in this field from being on the wrong
side.
But you know,
being on both sides of it.
But uh,
I've never heard of that.
I can't imagine why I supplement company would do that.
And this supplement company wasn't like Tim Means his company or Eol Ramirez,
they came out with a press release instantly.
So do not put this on us.
Let us know what you need from us.
We'll drop it off at the lab ourselves.
Jamie,
see if you find this online,
because someone told me about it this weekend and I never got a chance to look
at.
Someone said that there are certain things in supplements that you know,
could have been sold by a company that would allow you to test positive for
these very things.
See if,
see if you can find that in,
in relationship to John Jones is test.
Cause I remember someone talking about it and I said,
I got to remember to look this up.
It's only there only those two chemicals.
The only exist like in a pharmaceutical world,
right?
Yeah,
that's right.
So it's not like it's a root or something.
No.
Okay.
And then what exactly they got him for me that that's still coming out.
But that was one of the things,
again to go back to the press conference and I think,
I think John did more good than he did bay.
I think it was kind of a good thing that came out.
He show courage.
He didn't read the script,
he answered all the questions.
But the bad was he didn't tell us what he tested positive for.
Right.
And the bad news.
Now he's stuck with speculation.
If he were to come out and tell us exactly what it was,
you and I won't have to gas and go to the Internet and Spec and speculation and
rumors is which what you don't need.
Right.
I don't know why he held that with understanding.
Osada is going to tell us if you don't tell us who Sada,
I don't think they know.
No,
I don't.
I really,
I think if they're going to charge him and they getting sued,
we have,
they're going to charge him and they are within the event.
Oh,
that I'm going for for breaking only one year.
Like y'all take it,
go information,
you'll take it.
No,
not if it's medical information.
I suppose you're right with Hipaa,
but this doesn't fall under that.
The commission is going to bring charges against him for certain supplements are
going to bring him in,
require that he's there.
They're going to have to address it.
Then he's going to say his piece,
look,
I took this.
I didn't think I'd get caught or I don't know anything about it.
That's,
that's a route guys go as well,
but the bottom line is it's going to come out.
I thought he had a good opportunity to tell us what it was and perhaps give a
guess as to how it got an assist him if he's going to take that path.
The outright denial path,
that's not a great one historically,
but some guys take it if that's the route he's going to go down outright denial.
Tell us what it is.
Okay.